great to see
this man here in the flesh i love you
sir i don't care who knows at giancarlo
esposito great to see you great to see
you as well uh i mean spectacular
i i'm a die-hard fan of the show and i
see this and i know what i'm thinking
what are you thinking oh wow i'm
thinking a whole bunch of things you
know i read the scripts and then i see
uh the visual imagery that they put
together and i gotta tell you it's uh it
is stellar stellar and when you start to
watch this show the tension just keeps
rising
and the morality of the show keeps
begging the question who are you where
do you stand uh it is uh explosive and
it is engaging and it's the best
television ever you know what i i i
cannot argue with a single word you just
said
and the you know the amazing thing about
it especially just seeing that and and
just hearing you say what you just said
about seeing it from the script to the
screen and our terrestrial radio
audience just as uh back here on the
rich eisens show we just saw a um
a trailer for the final season six and
final season to better call saul and the
man who plays gusfing giancarlo esposito
here in studio
that um i
the remarkable aspect about the the
drama that's built up
is you know we know
it's not even a spoiler alert that this
is a prequel we know your character is
going to
survive right we know jimmy mcgill aka
saul goodman's going to survive we know
jonathan banks his character is going to
make it to
to the next you know day breaking bad
but it's i'm still on the edge of my
seat it's unbelievable it's truly
amazing because you get a chance to see
how these people make the decisions that
got them to where you're going to pick
them up or where you already know
they've be they've arrived and to do
that dramatically vince gillingan and
peter gool who is the showrunner of this
particular show they are brilliant at
creating that tension that allows you
moment-to-moment edge of your seat
filmmaking
every frame is is like a film it's a
visual story and they've mastered the
visual story uh i'm so proud to be a
part of this show in this new
incarnation to better call saul that is
not a bookend you know many people think
it'll be a bookend to what breaking bad
was and uh they will go hand in hand but
there will be space and time in between
which is quite wonderful and this year
uh i've had a chance to also show myself
in another uh incarnation on this show
just dropping a little bomb um
and that's all i'll say all right oh
come on now
what do you mean another incarnation i
knew you're going to ask that rich
that's about these it's my job my
numbers are good my numbers are good
i mean you know it reminds me of the the
day i threw out the first pitch in
altoona baby you know and i was down in
the basement and that 90 feet is a long
way it's 90 feet you're gonna have to
wait to really find out um but i have
been inspired by this show in not only
as an actor but also in other
ways hmm what do you think this could
possibly mean i don't know i mean i
don't know i mean you're asking me i
don't know i'm just saying i'm just
saying because i'm again i'm i'm trying
to determine what you're picking up
because um
so i'm putting it down correctly okay
you will pick it up but don't linger on
it too long okay because if you pick it
up how about this have you played gus
fring for the last time in your
professional playing oh that's another
great question well you know i always
feel like every time this ends i have
but i always feel like i have more to
give
and i'm an actor so i want you the
audience to know everything about gus
frank but if you have
if you were able to know less there's
more mystery
and so just when i think it's over
vince gilligan says
you never know
boy do i love that yeah gus prequel well
you know i've always wanted and i'll
just say it i've always felt in my mind
there is
room
for the rise of gus
this shows about jimmy mcgill yes it's a
reflection of who we are and what we do
and what we become how you become
comfortable with that justify it and go
jimmy has a line and
i think it's the fourth season i'm good
at this
and you know what
i'm good at this i can play this guy
and sooner or later you're going to see
the whole picture i believe
who are you channeling when you're when
you're
you're acting as gus frank the evil side
of me
my alter ego
your own personal alter ego i think you
know acting as a way of hearing healing
your personality and i think when you
drop into a character in such a way that
i do for a breaking bad and then
recreating gus spring for better call
saul i didn't want to do the same thing
this season for gus you're going to see
a very different gus than what you've
seen before
because of the pressure
we as human beings when we're under
pressure we either melt we acquiesce or
we stand up in some other way but with
that you see new colors and so you'll
see some new colors from gus in season
six a better call see this and that's
the beauty of this show um
you know if if you can just drill down
as to why this show is successful and
why breaking bad was successful removing
the imagery from it and and how you
pointed out going from script to screen
and how beautiful it looks and how
remarkable it is and how well it is shot
and how um unique it looks on the screen
it's all about decision making and what
you do in certain situations whether
it's pressure packed or it's all about
decisions you make and that's what
breaking bad
literally meant you know about the
character that brian cranston so
expertly played and was decorated for is
is this decision you know once he got
his his diagnosis and what he did with
it i bought my two daughters to the
premiere last night i remember when they
were 10 we'd go to a greek diner i'm the
last one to order they say papa how
could you be such a great actor you
can't make your mind on the menu
the menu in a greek diner is the same
and every day you go across america and
what do i want what do i want what i
want i'm not like that when i'm working
as an actor playing gus spring i love
what you said because i think uh
humility is involved for vince gilligan
for peter gould for all the writers in
the writers room and all the folks in
the set even though they have a template
to know the rhythm and know how they do
it i think they're still team players
and they're humble and they're present
the thing i realize about being
president is you never know what's going
to happen you know but we it's hard to
be present as an actor sometimes because
you want to figure it out so you don't
fumble the pill
right so you rehearse you rehearse like
me in the basement altoona throwing out
the first pitch right the guy said it's
90 feet they made me nervous it's 90
feet you better practice i'm in my hotel
room with a pillow against a chair
throwing the ball if you miss oh my god
the guy
keep your job keep your day job
right yes but you have to let all that
go when you hit the field same thing
with acting same thing with the writers
be present in the moment what's
happening right now
that makes this show defines this show
for what it is it's each moment that you
are present that you allow something new
to take place and then some of these
scenes i will watch it back two three
times oh my goodness no because i i i i
wanna make sure i'm picking up what is
being said
um there's always easter eggs there's
always an easter egg on this program but
also i just love the the acting i i love
it when you're doing what you're doing
and you're playing uh your character and
then there's another lead pipe wielding
professional doing that in the scene
right and um do you like do you
sometimes have to wind down after a
scene like say with jonathan banks or
with anybody else on that jonathan i i
love working with him yes the answer is
yes um the answer is there's a lot going
on in my mind when i play this character
um i love firstly i'll say what bob
odenkirk does
uh and he made me aware of something
last night at the big premiere so it
will come on april 18th of course you'll
all see it but he said you know i have a
lot of words to depict and to say what i
need to say as a character you have very
few how do you do it how do you allow
the audience to know so much with so
little to say yes uh and for me it's
been an exercise as an actor
for my physicality my body language
you're using your physicality body
language eyebrows eyes emotions but it's
all about what you're thinking
inside what are you thinking what are
you thinking um well when i'm in a very
difficult scene and every very difficult
moment i have moments with tony dalton
who is an amazing actor who plays lalo
salamanca this season where i'm just
furious
at his smarts and what he does
and i'm trying to figure out how to be
ahead of him so that's what i'm thinking
how do i get ahead of him
how do i how do i allow the audience to
know i don't believe what's taking place
i have questions there's something else
happening and then direct them to do
things
to help me know in my heart what really
is the truth
you dig so there's always a some tape
playing but it's not just a random tape
it's a tape that is directly connected
to the storyline of this show
and it's the thread comes from breaking
bad giancarlo esposito here on the rich
eisen show okay
um twice now you've mentioned this first
pitch i need to hear more about this
what are you talking about your first
pitch you threw a first pitch at a
altoona farm team a couple of years back
okay and my dear friend joe cosentino
who is um gone on to he used to play for
the red sox and we've got a big
matchup coming this weekend with the
yankees and the red sox that's great and
uh so i went down to the farm team to
throw out the first pitch and i was very
very nervous and i practiced in
the hotel room a few weeks before he
actually joe my dear big bear friend uh
he played for the red sox and then
eventually went to the yankees uh and uh
for you know short year or so
and uh he gave me a bunch of balls and
said you better practice it's a longer
distance than you think and i'm an
athlete and i was i don't know if you
know this right you may know this you
you know me a little bit i've been here
a few times yes i was a catcher in
little league
and so i that started my baseball fandom
and so i realized that my analogies come
from sports in my working career because
it just doesn't happen overnight you
practice you feel it you know you you
have to figure out
i loved you earlier even today you said
the guy's got soft hands
you know how you know how to have a
strong arm accurate arm but yeah have
the right feel touch that's what i do in
my work so that throwing out that pitch
made me real nervous i practiced for a
long time and guess what i threw a
strike at a boy i threw a first pitch at
dodger stadium um and i was so nervous i
actually went to a mound and practiced i
had to because you know if you screw it
up it's on youtube forever and um so uh
i i uh would have hit the right-handed
hitter but my lefty uh left-handed vader
would have swung and missed at my junk
it would have gone right out of the zone
that's the way i'm looking at it
love it yeah it didn't bounce it it
wasn't embarrassing good so we've gone
through it by the way tj jefferson over
your right shoulder
altoona have you ever been to that game
he's from altoona yeah
wow
that's my home town yeah
baseball that's the the the pirates uh
affiliate there now too now it is yeah
so this is 2014 around that time you
said it was just a couple years ago
okay yeah it's a great stadium and what
i refer to in the basement is they have
a pitcher's mound in the basement okay
at that stadium uh that is obviously the
the stats are exactly right right uh but
it's i was shocked it's a bunker in the
basement and there's a mound and you're
not 90 feet and there's the plate and
the whole deal but it still didn't tell
the story of getting out there people
screaming
out in the open air and being on that
mound i just do what i do for gus ring
deep breaths calm down
focus
and get it across the plate baby but i
only had to do it one time rich that's
it that's all it is these other guys got
to do it over and over and over again
and then when you were a catcher for a
little league in the bronx were you was
it danny almonte on the mound was that
that
yeah right the uh
well i mean he's just you're the same
age right is it still too soon
how old was he instead of being in 30
years 23. he was supposed to be 12 but
he was 14. oh oh is that what it was oh
that's not that he was throwing like 95
or something like that everybody oh my
god unbelievable so did you have any pop
in your bat as a catcher as little
league at all yeah i was a very uh i was
a very good banner okay yep absolutely
you know i was i was a strong kid you
know i was hefty
and uh i i i think my i think my mother
she came to one game two games here or
there
and uh you know i i got a throw down
from the third baseline to home plate
yes i got i caught a a runner in between
and uh you know one throw back and forth
i was a very good runner and i just put
the ball in my hand and i just ran at
him i i knew i was going to get to him
before he got back to third yeah and uh
but he turned and he tried to slip me
and i just put the ball right in his gut
my mother was like did you just punch
him in the stomach
i said no the ball did
it wasn't me it's not you it was the
ball come on mommy
so who was your guy growing up was it um
thurman months airman monson i was
literally going to say those i knew your
name was thurman
being a catcher in little league and
you're you're he was from ohio my mother
was from cleveland i grew up for a
part-time in cleveland it was all
connected in some way you know um
baseball to me is just uh a champions
game it really is and you have that
patience and it moves a little faster
than golf i heard you talk about tiger
we love them the masters
[Laughter]
i love it but thurman was your guy huh
he was my guy me too and i remember i
was in summer camp when i heard the
awful news about him yes indeed it's
like one of those moments flash bulb
memory for me where i just go yeah i
think it's the first time i realized
that you die
you know yes 1979 79 you know there is
there is some limit on our timing we and
some of us don't know when
and uh that's okay give us a lot of joy
as um we all want to bring joy to our
world in in certain ways and little
things make you happy
and for me it's the little things in
life that really allow me to to realize
how much we affect each other like that
plaque on your desk yeah best dad ever i
know we're we're we're we'll do battle
on that front um giancarlo esposito here
on the rich eisen show okay so let's
combine two of your loves and passions
baseball and acting why not okay uh to
your right sir underneath your hat is a
rich eyes and show card we have written
down on it three sentences that are a
promo like a baseball broadcast promo
promoting the upcoming game
between the yankees and the red sox on
opening day i'd like you to read these
uh words and three different characters
that you've played okay
uh first one i'd like you to read
these words as a community friendly
gus ring
the gust fring that is out there in the
world nobody knows
who you are you're you're los poyos
hermanos you're the guy who's you know
selling chicken okay love it and also
giving out checks to community
you know uh groups things like that the
fun run this is here we go uh so go
forward to john carlo esposito it's
opening day
and it's a battle
of good versus evil the lightest chapter
of the long-standing rivalry between the
boston red sox and the new york yankees
from yankee stadium in the bronx the sun
is out
and it
is a great day for baseball
now that we have that i'd like you to
read it as drug warlord gus frank
if you can channel that right now and
read the same lines
it's opening day
and it's a battle of good vs evil
the latest chapter
of the long-standing rivalry between the
boston red sox and the new york yankees
from yankee stadium in the bronx
the sun is out
and it is a great day
for baseball
[Laughter]
oh my gosh rich you're just like you're
fun i love being put on the spot by you
okay here we go i'm scared right now and
here's the last one then here's one one
one more all right one more i'd like you
to read this as moth gideon
the evil moff gideon
who you play so expertly
in the mandalorian
if you don't mind
you have something i want
[Music]
it's opening day
and it's a battle of good versus evil
the latest chapter of the long-standing
rivalry between the boston red sox and
the new york yankees
from yankee stadium in the bronx the sun
is out
and it is a great day
for baseball
[Applause]
master class what fun you are
now how would a big brother on my team
there you go baby
oh when do i when do when do i and uh my
children the whole family get more
mandalorian you'll get it soon uh you'll
get it soon i've got a little few things
to do in regard to that to put some
finishing touches on what i do okay uh
but i believe it'll be sometime this
summer no date set yet but coming soon
okay how
again uh i'm i'm just assuming but when
the star wars
folks whoever that might be or disney
folks reach out to you and say would you
like to be
the evil character
in the mandalorian in the star wars uber
the first television show based on it
how quickly do you say yes to that oh my
goodness john favreau called me said i
have good news and bad news i said
what's the good news he said i wrote a
role for you
in uh mandalorian
specifically for you and i said wow
fantastic what's the bad news the bad
news is all the money's going on the
screen
and i said is there more good news
[Laughter]
how about backhand baby
and he said to me disney's doing it wow
i have nothing but great things to say
about this studio about this franchise
in regard to how they have enlightened
our children to mythology and to what's
right and how to go about doing what's
right how to be in service the
mandalorian service and thankfully they
i've been on another job in new york and
pandemic hit things have gotten backed
up and they have waited for me with such
wonderful love and respect for me to
come back and and do what i do um and
love to do so uh this is a great show
you say yes and then you say
i've got one caveat john he's like oh
what's that i said
i must have a cape
yeah damn straight baby
damn straight you've got to have a cape
baby of course you do
i gotta tell you i had no idea you were
in it i had no idea and we're watching
it my wife susie and and i who are huge
fans of yours and everything else that
you've done and my kids as you might
imagine they have they're 13
11 and eight so subtract a year and a
half or whatever the first season of
mandalorian we were watching it is they
have yet to see
you know do the right thing and better
call saul and and you know they get to
see they haven't seen the usual suspects
yet and so you pop up as moff gideon
and it dawns on me that you are now the
evil character
the vader of this equation that's right
okay and i pause it and my wife and i
explain to them how lucky they are that
you are playing this character i swear
to you we did this it's just like hey
you know
his name is giancarlo esposito
you this is this is amazing like you are
in you're in you're in good shape here
thank you so much no it's true a
meaningful thing for young people to
understand that the the deep link
between
good and evil and stories of service
like mandalorian that excites them is a
deep mythology of historical relevance
and for me to be involved in this show
extends um the kind of spiritual
elements that i believe in but the human
elements that we need in our world right
now i'm with you uh i'm i'm with you
okay um i gotta just return to this
so
chris
he took off his hat when he said that
there's gonna be i noticed that too okay
you had your hat uh
literally my mind's been churning
throughout the rest of this interview
okay so
what what what do we got here i don't i
i was thinking it was just something not
even on screen that maybe he's directing
a few episodes like i'm not sure no i
mean that could by the way i'm all in on
that
changing hats like the figurative thing
like changing hats that's kind of what
that was my first reaction to that okay
i love that you guys are on to something
i'll just you know i look hey you guys
got to figure it out i can't give you
too many keys no i know you know what
chris is a smart guy tj behind me he's
on it except he's learned today how to
say big brother on my team and uh and i
said to you don't think too hard so
chrissy baby
there you go on it okay on it
all right
you know we learn from doing and
we learn from our experience
and i'm grateful for the experience to
be able to do a bunch of different
things this season
and better call april 18th april 18th
can't wait um and the premiere was last
night it was
fantastic night american legion hall uh
never been there before a great setting
uh all the folks came out you know the
gauntlet is being passed on amc
um i am so happy to be with them as a
new home for my new show okay called the
driver
um we begin production in may our
production office opens we start
shooting in july and uh they're banking
on me for a new show for them it's
completely different than anything
you've seen before okay is that anything
else you want to you can tell us about
it
you know it's a unlikely um story about
a driver who's down on his luck can't
support his family having trouble
getting his kid through college okay and
uh he gets involved with the nefarious
um
african
i would say human trafficker okay of
note who has some political relevance in
new orleans and
he has no idea what he's getting into
and he's over his head very quickly and
has to get out so and you play the
i play uh vince bourgeois the driver the
front that yesterday
through his eyes and
i wanted to do this for the people of
america because
i started to think about what my life is
like yes where i've been where i've come
from and about how people struggle to
make ends meet and i wanted to do a
story about an every man and every man
good good person can't make it happen
and he has to turn to some uh very shady
means to try to make it happen when he
realizes he's in too deep he realizes
doesn't he it's not equivalent with his
moral code and he's got to get out so
there are people across america trying
to make it and i wanted to represent
that every man every woman who's trying
so hard but it's not happening well you
have me in anything you do you know that
so
and i hope the rest of my audience feels
the same way i know they do um the sixth
and final season the better call saul
premieres on monday april 18th with
back-to-back episodes come on let's go
let's go and then uh the final portion
of the 13 episode final season hits on
july 11th thank you any time here yeah
i'm truly appreciative of you stopping
by here always have fun here thank you
truly right back at you thank you hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here